-Guys, it is time for
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Now, we do this thing every
week where I send out a hashtag,
and I ask you guys to respond to
that topic.
So, with the Oscar nominations
coming out yesterday, I sent out
the #AddAWordFixAMovie."
And I asked you to tweet out
a funny word addition
to improve a movie title.
Within minutes it was
a trending topic in the U.S.,
so thank you for playing along.
We love it.
Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#AddAWordFixAMovie tweets
from you guys.
Here we go.
This first is from @vegestic.
-Ah, veggie stick.
-Veggie stick. Thank you.
She says...
-Oh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Beautiful thing.
-This one's from @joopydrawers.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one's from
@timothydalton11. He says...
[ Applause ]
-Got to give him his props.
-I'd watch it.
-Got to give him the props.
-This one is from
@pierrelafrance0. He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one's from @julieindallas.
She says...
[ Applause ]
This is from @snsdough.
He says...
[ Applause ]
-Ed Inisherin.
-This one is from @alexvanpelt.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one's from @yupimdestiny.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
And this last one is
from @jeffhofmann. He says...
There you have it, everybody.
Those are "Tonight Show"
hashtags.
To check out more of
our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.